okay so I'm gonna talk to you about CSS
for color I guess you all know about CSS
and your honor about css3 color you'll
know let's stuff you know hashes and RGB
parens and all that stuff and I'm one of
the editors of CSS for color and the
problem that I find is not that people
don't understand the syntax but they say
to me actress this is great but what
does it all mean why would I want to use
this what can I do so most of this talk
is going to be about what is color what
can you do with color and right at the
end
don't worry right at the end we'll get
back to CSS okay so a quick bit about me
that's me in case you were wondering not
wearing suit in this photo I'm a
technical director of the World Wide Web
Consortium w3c I work for Tim
berners-lee who invented the web and I
started SVG by which I mean I got the
people together to actually make SVG
wrote the requirements document and made
sure that people actually kept going
until it was finished I also chaired the
working group that produced it I was one
of the co-authors of the PNG format I've
worked in web fonts for a while the
group that did at font face I chaired
that I've worked on one and wife two
more recently chromatic fonts called
multicolored fonts but Maurice more
relevantly for this talk I was the first
chair of the CSS working group I'm
currently a staff contact I was one of
the edges of CSS too and in particular
relevant CSS for color co-editor with
sab Atkins so let's see what are we
going to talk about today well first of
all we're going to cover some basics so
we're all on the same page
then we're going to talk about how do
you measure color then I'm going to talk
about something called CIE la B does
anyone here know what that is already by
the way feel free to leave if so No okay
good
then you're going to talk about
measuring color displays and what you
can do with color displays then in case
any of you use CSS for print I'm going
to talk about see my King and lastly the
actual relevant bit I guess you could
say what does the assess for color bring
to this that you'll now know how
to use so basics what is that on screen
what is it a prism what does a prison do
it splits light what happens when light
splits it goes into different colors
that's right how do you know it goes
into different colors because you can
see them right now we have all the parts
that we need there's light and it splits
into colors and we know that it does
that because we can see it what about
bumble bees you can see bumblebees
thanks thanks there for that Bruce apart
from being able to see bumble bees can
bumbles where you see colors yes they
can do they see the same ones as us no
what about snakes they can see infrared
so what we've learned here is light is
made up of multiple colors when they're
all combined together it makes white
when you split them apart then you see
colors great so if you remember physics
at school you remember that light is an
electromagnetic wavelength it has it has
wavelengths click next slide thank you
so we'll define light for the purposes
of this talk as wavelengths which are
visible to humans and there that means
that it's not an objective physics
phenomenon it's not something that you
can measure directly you have to include
the human being which is observing it
and that's actually quite important and
you'll see why later so here's the
visible spectrum from red to violet or
going off to infrared and ultraviolet
and you'll see some numbers there which
are in nanometers and don't worry about
those but anyway there's a range of
colors which we can see and we can see
them because of the human eye don't
worry about all of the stuff on there
that's labeled the only thing we care
about is the retina which is the bit at
the back which actually collects light
and produces electrical impulses so
let's stop reading those other late I
told you to stop reading them you don't
need to know about that stuff the retina
is made up of cells a bunch of different
cells the ones are we going to
concentrate on are called cones because
someone in a fitted man is looking
through a microscope thought they look
vaguely conical anyway there are cones
are in fact three different types of
cones and
it's because of that that we have color
vision if we only had one sort we would
see in black and white like dogs do
allegedly I've never met one to ask so
here are the responses of the three cone
types to light and what you can see
there is that they react in the middle
range they're very sensitive in sort of
yellow-green areas and then they're not
very sensitive at read sort of violets
and then there's this other one which is
so small it barely comes off the axis
which is clearly different by the way if
you were designing a system to pick up
color this would be a really bad design
okay this is obviously a case of
unintelligent design also knows
evolution because to two of the cones
are almost the same except for being
wanna be a bit less than the other and
the third one we actually have to put it
onto a logarithmic axis until we can see
you remember logarithms right no powers
of ten and all that sort of stuff okay
so there's the purple one we can finally
see it by the way I've colored these as
yellow yellow green and purple just to
reinforce the fact that that's the
wavelengths that they're most sensitive
to you because of that in in crappy
textbooks you'll often see these
referred to as the red green and blue
cones and now you see why that's a bad
name for them so and lastly just
pointing out the human brain is an
integral part of that in fact the retina
is a part of the human brain it's just a
part that happens to be wrapped around
the back of your eyeballs the orange
part there is the visual cortex I
mentioned that just so you know where it
is it doesn't actually matter
so now audience participation time what
I want you to do is to look at that
black dot in the middle of the screen
and I will attempt to hypnotize you for
30 seconds keep looking at it do not
look away do nots that start scanning
around looking the audience just keep
looking at that for about 30 seconds
you've done ten of them already keep
going keep going
you are feeling very sleepy oh no that's
the lunch what color do you see green
why magic no opponent colors yes yes
it's the opponent colors that's right
basically this the light-sensitive cells
in your retina got a bit tired from
looking at the same thing all the time
without moving around like they normally
do and then once they got tired then
when they saw white some of them gave up
and only saw parts of white let's do
that again
if this clickable move god thank you
okay try again 30 seconds look at the
central dots the reason you look at the
central dots to make sure the same part
of your retina is focused all the time
on the same area otherwise you get less
of an effect keep going you know there's
no trickery this time no hypnotism I
will take two volunteers up on stage
those two with my glamorous assistant
who will embarrass them yes and you'd if
any cuts there did you get a yellow yes
okay good so there is this concept of
opponent colors and this is very
important we'll see why later
actually let's go back to well I was not
I'll just look at this slide and if you
saw yellow and you saw red and you
wanted to mix them together you would
already have a name for that right you
could call it a yellowish red or indeed
orange and if you saw a yellow and a
blue and you mix them together you
wouldn't call it a yellowish blue you've
never seen a yellowish blue why because
their opponent colors you can't see them
both at one Sigma and you see one or the
other
let's get to the color in the middle
white this is a photo taken in a hotel
room of a piece of white paper and I
switched off the auto white balance on
the camera deliberately and it looks
yellow but at the time to me it looked
white and if I took it outside into the
Sun and looked at it it would look white
and if I took into the shade it would
still look white the light levels are
hugely different in these three
scenarios and yet my brain is Kate
although saying this is a white sheet of
paper it's always white the light levels
are changing all over the place but your
brain is adjusting things for what makes
sense it's adjusting things for what's
relevant on what's irrelevant
information if the Sun goes behind a
cloud that doesn't matter that
everything the view you see of the world
is the same so we do a lot of this we do
it we adapt to what's called the primary
white and color systems that don't take
account of that have problems I Kings
have problems with that as well actually
if you if you take away the context if
you just crop right down so you don't
really know what the defining white is
then you can be led to believe that
addresses blue when in fact it's clearly
white so color let's define color now
it's a subjective sensation it's not
objective it's not directly physically
measurable in the brain and it's caused
by visible light acting on the eye well
that should make you scared by now how
are we going to define it because it's a
nebulous subjective sensation go thank
you
well you should be scared frankly
because that is kind of a dubious thing
I mean maybe we need an entire spectrum
all measured and and we need electrodes
in the brain and we need dissecting eyes
and and no actually it turns out we
don't need to do all that it turns out
there are a number of simplifying things
which we can use on which I will show
you so science to the rescue how do you
measure color if I haven't forgot it in
my hotel room I would hold up a large
black device like this and I would say
this is a spectrum job just work with me
here come on work with me this this is a
spectrum of drama do you believe in the
spectrophotometer yes thank you you do
and uses to measure things like this so
at every different wavelength it
measures the intensity of the light that
it finds at that wavelength and it gives
you a nice little graph or a table of
numbers like this so from this you can
clearly say that this is what color is
this by the way does anyone know I
didn't with unless I looked it up this
is actually a fluorescent light bulb who
would know it's a slide deck yes so I
cheated I looked at the title that's
true but apart from that yes you
wouldn't know there are ways to work out
what colors something is but looking at
a spectrum directly doesn't actually
tell you let's see what we do know if
you get people and you show them a
single wavelength and you get them to
rate against in other wavelengths and
see which one is brighter so using the
human as a comparing system you'll find
that as we saw already wavelengths in
the middle yellow green ones we can see
those as really bright you should be
looking at this sort of orangey line
here ignore the dashed one which is what
happens when you're looking under
moonlight which is a bit different so
that we know already know that the
system as a whole has a peak sensitivity
in yellow green and goes off towards the
vials in the red so that's the first
piece of information we have and we
already know why ranks already showed
you this diagram you basically add those
three up and that's what you get
next thing a visual match you can have
two colors that look identical right you
put them side-by-side this is the same
color we're very good at telling if two
colors are the same especially if
they're right next to each other but
they can have wildly different spectra
so there's something going on here and
of course the thing that's going on is
we only have three color channels coming
out the eye because we only got three
cone types so we can combine these in
various ways but at the end of the day
we don't have a full spectrometer in our
brains so they did this in the 1930s
they got three lamps together they were
mercury lamps I've dropped two of them
the wavelengths there but don't worry
about that trust me there were three
wavelengths and the reason they did that
was because all the different labs in
the world could do the same experiment
because of the physics of mercury lamps
they make very narrow wavelength bands
and the idea was you had three
blinders and there was a color you could
see on one side and you had to match it
with these three lamps and they did that
for all the different wavelengths all
the way through to see how much of each
you needed to match now the observant um
are there any observant among you yes
does anyone wonder why there are lights
on the other side as well you can be
honest no you didn't you didn't care
okay that's fine
the lights on the other side is because
some things can't be matched in
particular you turn the red slider all
the way down and it's still one map
scene and to actually add red on to the
other side you have to cheat and add
more red to the unknown color and then
it will match which is fine you just
call it a negative value which is
cannibal fortunate especially in the
1930s when people did everything using
pencils and paper and log tables and
slide rules and stuff but you can do it
so you can define a matching color with
just three numbers you don't need the
whole spectral data nonsense and that's
good three numbers is workable we can
deal with three numbers so then they
took that experimental data and they
transformed it into a system called CIE
XYZ at CIE just stands for Committee on
Internacional directly Raj which means
international lighting Commission in
French which they used a lot in those
days but so ignore that part but X Y Zed
was a much more reasonable thing and the
first thing that made it reasonable was
that they got rid of all the negative
numbers which was nice and they did so
using a thing called supersaturated
imaginary primary isn't it don't worry
about it because you don't need to know
but in particular of those three
primaries one the y channel is called
the luminance in other words it's that
same function we saw about high in the
middle yellow-green area so it tells you
how bright something appears the X
unsaid together tell you what color it
is in a way that's difficult to actually
understand when you just look at the
numbers but it does so if you've got XYZ
measurements of something you can tell
for example what sort of white it is you
can measure what's the Y from that light
and is it different from the light from
that light that sort of thing so it's
good and it's additive what does
additive mean so imagine I'm honest
no you don't have to do that okay I am
on a stage imagine I am standing
underneath that blue light and then
there's a I don't know a magenta light
over there and they start moving towards
each other them they want to know what
color will they make when they meet you
can do that if you've measured that one
in Xyz F and you measured that one in X
Y Zed you can just average the two
numbers and you actually get the
measured result when the light poles
coalesce you'll get the correct result
that's what additive t means it means
you can do sums you can do
multiplication addition and things on
numbers and get meaningful results there
are some downsides however to X Y Z this
is a gradient of luminance from naught
to 100 and I have outlined where the
middle gray is and you'll see that
there's a problem with that
it's kind of not in the middle so what
does that mean well it means if it's not
perceptually uniform in other words the
distance apart two things are doesn't
relate to how different they appear to
you so it's a grid measurement it's good
for doing numbers in it's doing
calculations in but it's not good at
telling us how dissimilar two colors
will appear there's another issue white
adaptation remember I showed you the
picture of me holding up a piece of
white paper looking yellow and if I'd
had the time to take another piece of
white paper looking blue in the in
daylight so that's why adaptation the
fact that you will see those depending
on what the situation you find yourself
as white isn't handle X Y Zed is great
to tell you what kind of white am I
seeing right now but it's not good at
saying if we ignore all that and assume
my eyes are adapted to white what color
do I really see so we need a new system
derived from X Y Zed which is more
adapted to human vision and that one is
called CIE la B so the previous system I
was telling you about days to 1931 this
one's much more recent 1976 you can see
why it hasn't caught on on the web guys
it's so new it's okay so there's the l
axis of L a B and as you can see mid
gray has the desirable property of being
right in the middle which you are so
already we're off to a good start
and comparing that to luminance you can
see the difference there yes so we want
to be now there are two axes called a
and B which together so the L axis is
all the lightness brightness information
at a and B are how colorful it is and
each of a and B can be positive or
negative if a is towards the positive
end it's a sort of pinky purpley color
and on the negative end it's a sort of
what's called what's that called teal
magenta teal or something like that
turquoise you'll notice there that
there's a minus 40 which is greyed out
and you won't care to hazard a guess why
it's grayed out you can see without the
I so good answer but wrong anyone else I
did make the fire that way why did I
make a slide that way and you keep
answering for being a smartass until you
tell me the right answer the reason
being that not that the eye can't see it
but the monitor the projector can't
display it it's too bright is too
saturated that color is outside the
gamut as they say I'll explain gamut
later so that's the a axis and that the
axis goes from the sort of mustardy
yellow to sky-blue
okay so put those two together and you
get this sort of thing it's a
three-dimensional space where light
neutral grays and whatever are always up
the middle axis L goes from naught to
100 very conveniently it doesn't matter
how bright it is you just include the
brightness the reference white and scale
to naught to 100 so it's very easy to
use and then there's a and B which okay
they represent colors it's quite nice
but it's kind of like jiggling with RGB
sliders to make a particular color you
need to fiddle with it and then you
fiddle with it again and you guess and
you hope and get it wrong because you
can sort of see it but it's difficult to
know exactly what values would give you
a color you wanted so let's put that in
a nice polar form we've got a hue wheel
now with red at roughly 30 degrees okay
that's better that's more reasonable so
we now have a hue angle sweeping around
we're just thrown a rectangular to polar
conversion and then chromo which is how
colorful it is sort of similar to
saturation not quite at this point you
may be thinking hang on I've heard about
this soon yeah you're selling me
something I've already got we've already
HSL right HSL already has a hue angle he
already has a brightness this is the
same thing look at this diagram and look
at the yellow and look at the blue and
tell me if those look the same lightness
to you to your eyes do they know they
all have a both however have the value
of L equals 50 in this system which is
lying to you actually this system came
out in 1978 two years after the CIE
system moon was an attempt to bring a
similar sort of hue angle type system to
RGB with a few simplifying things like
not ever telling you what color it
really is okay so color displays this is
a picture of a color display with a
device hanging on the front measuring
the screen why would you want to do such
a thing because you want to know exactly
how your device behaves what happens if
you don't have that well that's okay
because maybe you can't afford one
they're not that expensive but maybe you
can't afford one but the people who made
your screen certainly can and they
probably did some of this just as
quality control shipping out of fact
training increasingly you'll find that
screens come pre calibrated pre-measured
some of them even with a certificate if
they're charging a bit more showing what
the values were so characterization is
basically you measure the color of red
at different levels and then a green at
different levels and then blue at
different levels you can do these
separately because it's another example
of an additive color space and once you
measure that you can calibrate it if
you'll find that if you do a neutral
grayscale there's areas where it's a bit
too blue in areas where it's a bit too
Brown and so on and given that numerical
data you've measured you can do
correction curves look-up tables to give
you a neutral grays and to give you the
white point that you want not so bluish
white that you'll get by default but a
nice neutral white
which gets us to the gamut the range of
colors that can be correctly displayed
the the actual color of full red full
green full blue gets measured and then
you can work out what the gamut is now
if any of you ever gone shopping for a
high-end monster like you know one that
you'd use on Photoshop and you'd use
Adobe RGB and that sort of things anyone
use such things any designers in the
audience I'll just go home then but if
you have done then you live look to
advertising and the advertising will
have diagrams like this which does have
the merit of being in two dimensions and
has the disadvantage of lying to you
again you will - you'll see something
with a triangle on there and it'll tell
you this monitor is wonderful because it
has this shape but this is a
two-dimensional slice out of XYZ
remember I said X Y Zed is not very good
at comparing colors and that means it's
not very good at comparing the gamut
over different devices instead you want
to be in three dimensions so here is an
example this is a top-down view of la
vie space and we're looking at the srgb
gama srgb is what CSS uses what HTML
uses is what canvas uses they're all
defined in terms of srgb which in terms
intent again is defined in terms of
actually the reference monitors use for
HDTV that's where the colors come from
so there it is I'm going to show you
this again in a minute but for now look
at that shape and compare it to a real
device oops this is someone's MacBook
Air which I was gently laughing at
having measured it because well it's a
bit small actually isn't it it's not as
good as srgb but it's okay and then
let's look at sort of nice high end
monitor it's nothing much larger that
shows you the right the full range of
colors that could be produced and it can
produce more colors than an sRGB can and
of course this is a top-down view but
that's less interesting what we really
want to be able to do is grab hold of
this and play with it and look at it in
three dimensions like that and then we
can have a better idea of how these
things compare so if you actually are
buying a high-end monitor and you see
volume if you see gamut volume mention
that is a much better measure of what
range of colors it can produce
so this is a high-end monitor this is
something you can do all of Adobe RGB
and display it correctly ok so now we
get the under idea that we can look at
different devices and we can see what
range of colors they produce and what's
the problem with device dependent colors
is that you'll have seen this yourself
you display the same color on different
machines and they look different it was
what we actually want is device
independent color if it's within the
gamut it can be displayed correctly but
the trick is you have to know what value
used to feed the monitor it's not going
to be the same for each monitor you just
green now let's see I've got five
minutes left and we've got CMYK how many
people are interested in printing one
two not very many
I'm going to do this quickly therefore
this is a dot screen from CMYK printing
basically the inks are opaque and so if
you put them all on top of each other
you wouldn't see them so they use this
dot pattern skewed around at various
angles so that they you get less overlap
and that's how you simulate color so
again we characterize in this case
though it's different instead of
measuring them that the cyan magenta
yellow et cetera separately you have to
measure every possible combination one
every possible because there's loads of
them but basically you print out a sheet
like that except much bigger and you
measure every single patch laborious ly
and if you're an office junior then that
takes you all afternoon and if you're a
sort of professional print shop you have
a thing that's automated like a robot
that just measures them all that guy's
did it and it's great that's fast and
then given that data you can calibrate
it you actually basically if you know
what color you want to produce you find
the patch that you measured that's
closest to it and then interpolate from
all the other patches and get a good
result and that data gets stored in a
thing called an ICC profile and I
mention this because we will mention we
look at ICC profiles in a minute so that
basically is that if you ever wanted to
do CSS that also is used for making a
book or making printed materials you
would want an ICC profile for the
printer that's going to be used ok last
finally CSS for color
what you may be asking by the way why is
there a sheep if we have time for
questions I'll explain the sheep
otherwise it will just be a mystery so
this is what css3 color does for you so
let's pretend our high-end monitor and I
got this RGB value and it looks fine
it's a non money I'm high-end designer
it looks cool on my monitor I go over
some lowly peon and look on their
monitor and it's all pale and I see
what's because you got a rubbish monitor
and they are actually inexperienced but
clever and they say no it's because you
failed to account for the gamuts of the
two devices and I go so I did actually
so this is what happens now I mean the
color I'm seeing here on the screen the
color you're seeing over there from the
projector are wildly different right
they're not a bit different they're a
lot different so well what can we do
about that well we could hack it that's
the first response there's a new media
query in media queries for about the
color gamut so I say okay well if you've
got a p3 gamut which is a sort of medium
wide gamut then I'll use this value and
then I'll put it go into a color
calculator and what work out what the
value should be and say otherwise rest
on GB then I'll get that this is really
horrible isn't it this is a do not ever
do this this is just me showing you what
you'd have to do and how different the
values would be to get the same color
yeah you get the same color but it is
ugly well answered there's a third
monitor fourth no no surfaces the
projector is not gonna work instead use
this LCH derive from leb you've got
lightness chroma hue angle the browser
itself works out what the RGB values
should be because it knows what your
screen is and then you get the same
color on every single one that is the
point of using it also the fact that you
can get physical devices you can measure
something and say what color is this
suit and that sort of thing what colors
the shirt and then you can put that
straight into your web page so that's
pretty handy let's look at the syntax
now so there's LCH just takes three
numbers l CH pretty simple if you put a
comma then the next value is the Alpha
and if you put another comment there's a
fallback value so you can give for older
devices that are
stand it or they don't have color
management systems you can give them a
full Bank value in srgb same for LA B
which you can use there is again three
parameters ICC color so you can actually
say I'm using this predefined color
space DCI p3 which is a wide gamut
monitor and rec 2020 which if you use
that now good luck to you because that's
a massively why Gamma monitor that
people are having real difficulty making
but in the future it will be more
relevant the broadcasts interest is
using that we picked these two standards
because they are standards there's no
point of defining something else it
already exists and lastly o'meara
queries for by alma also already
mentioned that media queries for can
help you there if you are actually going
to a printer then there's an app font
like the app font face there's an out
rule called at color profile where you
point off to your ICC profile and say
okay I'm defining this color and then
gonna use it in CMYK you see this four
frames is there CMYK and I can say
that's my color why would I care about
this because this is an actual measured
color I can convert it to la be from LA
B I can convert it to srgb that means I
can do things with this that composite
it I can you know use it in my screen
and get the right value get the right
color it's not one of these style shoes
that only works in print and doesn't use
that work on anything else yes I know
I'm out of time I'm almost there can I
use it well this is great Chris can I
use it
oh you can't actually this is brand new
a Brian really brand new is not in the
browsers Yahoo's only agreed in San
Francisco like two months ago at the
meeting we were at the first public
working draft is published next Tuesday
so you've got kind of a scoop here but
really when you look at the draft you'll
see the syntax and the syntax what you
say okay LC age parenthesis numbers now
you know why that's relevant and
important there is some more online the
slides are on github the specification
itself is on the CSS working group site
there's also some code which I wrote
which does color conversion so you want
to poke around at that you can have a
look there too
thank you very much
[Applause]